I actually want to call you my back to
something that we've I introduced before
but we didn't really use very much you
kind of knows don't we like that's
interesting and then we moved on from ok
this thing called the general term I've
shown you what it is I just haven't
given it the name is the idea I gave you
this kind of gone this kind of binomial
expansion to the power of seven is
probably just within reach of what would
you be expected to actually write out by
here this is a power of seven how many
terms will there be in the final
expansion he'll be a very good because
there we the zeroth term zero one two
three all the way up to seven and if you
can count the zero term that means eight
in total so that's just within reason to
write out and therefore if you needed to
solve a question that had this in it you
could potentially you can foreseeably
write the whole thing yeah but it
doesn't take very much to change this
question a little bit so that you're
like forget that I want to rather for
example if I just change the power okay
now this you would be mad to write out
you'd start writing it and then the Sun
would sit and you'd be like I want to
know okay see you wouldn't normally
expect this write this out nor would you
be like I mean this is the kind of
example where you could you could
physically write this out the enormous
paper you could but you're really just
costing yourself time like clearly by
putting this power here we're trying to
say to you hey you now have all this
more sophisticated machinery for
understanding this don't write the whole
thing here go straight to the part of it
that you want so what we did was we said
I could say this is equal to and then I
introduced this Sigma notation I did you
remember this this guy here right
Sigma come on what does Sigma why do we
use this weakness again what do the
signifies it signifies a sum hence s
four Sigma you're adding up a whole
bunch of things because now there are
not eight but eighteen terms in here so
I could say I could add up from N equals
zero that's the first term
that's the last mode of loss of a 70 and
every term in the expansion all 1800
gonna be in much the same format what's
the format going to me I'll give you
clue there are three pieces okay we're
gonna have the NCR bits and that's the
binomial coefficient know how to think
about this what will each of these
science on in your heart what is each of
these going to look like for this
particular expansion I'm on the 75 it so
it'll be 17 see whichever term that you
wants you count on there's the first
component what about the other two where
do you come from
yeah because with these matters right so
you're gonna get some number of these
how many so what I've done is I've like
I rename disclaimer there we usually
desmit in to be the road right so R is
which eternal long so I can take I've
got our of those which means that I'll
have negative two eyes how many of those
will I have okay so in total right by
the end you're gonna have something to
power up seventeen
so your first one you'll have none of
them and then there we one two three and
eventually you'll get to the last one
and you have that many okay does that
mean
now I should point out do you recall
because um because Pascal's triangle and
the expansion of this thing is
symmetrical it would be fair will be
equally fair to write this in reverse
order yeah I could write it like this
there's still going to be 0 to 17 terms
right this guy at the front if you're
writing forwards or backwards will be
the exact same series of numbers okay
but then I could write those around the
other way right I could say well let's
put this guy out the front like that and
then I can cut this guy out right if you
write out these whole things you would
get exactly the same thing just in
reverse order do that okay so the reason
why this is useful now is because rather
than having to write out the whole thing
if I want a particular term I can go
straight to it
for instance I have to say which term
has the X to the 13th in it right well
you don't have to write all of them out
until you get to exit 13
you could say okay well which one
actually would do it both ways
this is if I were to use this one which
term have X to the 13 you know I want
hello
there's the X's right in order to get X
to the 13 this 3x needs to be raised
2013 it's the only way you'll get 13 X
is exactly so therefore I want R equals
13 this our new 13 and this RV 13 right
so if I want the X to the 13 that guy
right I'm just going to go straight to
our equals 13 like so I'm going to say
17 see our 13 yes 3x to the team but
will the term on the ending
negative 2i to the 4 now had I chosen
this way had I written it this way I
could still do the same thing except it
won't be beyond bar equals 13 term that
will give me the X 13 which one will it
be
here we are equals 4 because remember
I've gone from the other direction right
so I'm just counting from the opposite
end so I would go okay that's fine
17 C 4 yes how many of these guys am I
gonna have to make it two ways I've
chosen R equals four this time right so
this is this is this guy
oh he which is unsurprising because we
already knew that and then of course
over here you've got 17 minus 4 which is
the 13 I was looking for like so right
so you can see oh yeah these are exactly
the same thing and I also know so these
guys are the same thing right remember
that so this is my NCR equals NC of n
minus R ok they're the same thing
and you can confirm that with your
factorial notation do you remember what
a pictorial notation for 17 c-13 would
be it's a fraction what's on the top 17
factorial something right at least one
alright so on the bottom there are me 13
factorial 4 thank toriel right that's
what I would write 5 root of that of
course if I had to go this the numerator
would be the same but then these guys
would just be the other way round which
is the same thing okay so that's why you
can continue self that yes this is
the same expansion